hello and welcome to my search engine
optimization or SEO tutorial series
where I plan to show you the legitimate
ways of going about SEO with your
website in the past the skill of SEO has
really been a matter of figuring out
what Google wants to see and giving it
to Google obviously that's no good
because it results in people making
websites for Google and not actual
people so Google's constantly trying to
fix this or at least make it to the
point where what Google wants is what
people want and really every year they
make pretty big changes to their
algorithms and all that stuff that
actually ranks a page and serves as a
result in someone's search obviously if
you think about it they must do this
because if you look at for example at
the early days the best way to get a
good page rank was to have a lot of
specific keywords and like some of the
top ranks niche sites for example really
just had bodies of text that made like
no logical sense but contained a bunch
of content specific keywords and strings
and stuff like this just to get ranked
since then really Google is made of a
ton of changes for how they actually
rank sites and find sites because they
have to if they're returning basically
spam sites then they're not really doing
their job very well and people aren't
getting the results that they're looking
for and in the end
Google's losing credibility the customer
is losing it's just it's not a good
situation and Google knows that so
Google really is constantly evolving and
is getting to the point where you know
what Google wants to see is what Google
believes people want to see as well or
at least experienced on your website so
that's really a case where SEO is more
of a function of just understanding your
customer and the customer experience or
the user experience on your website so I
mean of course there's still some basic
things that you can do to what I would
call accommodate Google but most of SEO
is really understanding the target
audience and taking into account a bunch
of customer experience factors like you
know the different browsers loading time
obviously your content
and a whole bunch of other stuff that
will actually start getting into and
that's really the way it ought to be
right you really ought to be making your
website for your user and Google should
really work around that so it's really
good that this is the way that SEO is
going so in the subsequent videos in
this series I'm gonna be covering what I
would say with scare quotes current SEO
practices
it is late September 2013 so these these
things might change but I really doubt
it because the road that Google is on
right now for and then as far as like
what you need to do right now for SEO is
pretty pretty good direction so I'm not
really sure too much of this stuff it
will change I also I urge you to ignore
anyone selling any sort of SEO tricks or
gimmicks or whatever and don't buy
things like backlinks and all that stuff
just don't do it instead what you really
want to do is learn how to get your
target audience and and how to make
their experience on your website the
best as possible while also being clear
to Google about what your website's
actually about in the end there really
is going to be no trick or gimmick but
the process of search engine
optimization is actually going to help
you improve your website there's still
will be obviously people who are gonna
try to cheat and even people who are
successful and cheating in the short
term but we have to understand as
Google's main focus with their search
engine is to eliminate cheating and
serve truly good results and I assure
you
Google's putting in way more effort here
than you could ever put into your
website and cheating so it really is
gonna be a losing game if you do try to
cheat so let's make our websites better
improve traffic and do a legit so if
that sounds interesting to you please
continue on to the next video in this
series as always thanks for watching